[Música]
cuántos o cuántas de vosotros os habéis
tenido alguna vez los labios de carmín
todos los que hacemos este gesto nos
sumamos a los que lo han hecho desde el
siglo 19 y quizás no todos seamos
conscientes que viene de la tuberculosis
la tuberculosis era fuente de
inspiración en el romanticismo
al toser sangre se pintaban los labios
de rojo y eso era considerado precioso
ellas protegían la piel con quitasoles
para recrear al máximo la palidez típica
del enfermo
el término sangre azul de la realeza
viene por la blancura y transparencia
que permitía que se vieran las venas
nicole kidman en mol angus
las mujeres solían vestir de blanco y
estrechaban la cintura con cortes vivían
leigh en lo que el viento se llevó'
precisamente ya murió de tuberculosis
como podían moverse así
pues cuanto más inmóviles quedaban ellas
menos necesitaban trabajar
lo que significaba que más pudientes
eran sus maridos económicamente al menos
me impresiona cómo podemos conocer
costumbres y formas de pensar del siglo
19 estudiando como vestían las mujeres
lo que me lleva a pensar que modas somos
todos la moda sociología incluso
filosofía y una clara ilustración de los
tiempos ojo en españa representa el 3%
del producto interior bruto y como
veíamos a lo largo de la historia los
diseñadores artistas fotógrafos
maquilladores se han inspirado en
diferentes enfermedades para crear
estética
en los 80 la plaga ya no era la
tuberculosis era el sida y la
drogadicción por proximidad todo el
mundo conocía a alguien con el problema
y esto se tradujo en imágenes
el hijo moribundo es un anuncio de
benetton un anuncio que se veía en las
revistas
en el vemos a una familia obesa velando
su hijo que se está muriendo de sida y
está hiper delgado las enfermedades
estaban dejando una importante huella en
la moda y también en lo cultural por
ejemplo el grupo joy división su
cantante ian curtis era epiléptico y se
drogaba
en el escenario alguna vez había sufrido
las convulsiones propias de la
enfermedad
estás
pronto fueron limitadas por los
espectadores
yo soy debía ritmo diurno pero si vais a
un festival de música electrónica como
el solar aún se baila sip
y hoy triunfa también la cantante billy
ellis que prefiere un chándal ancho una
minifalda para el escenario y en las
fashion week' las estilistas combinan
vestidos con bambas año tras año la
supuesta locura también ha sido musa
en el banquete de platón y a ser
relacionado con la genialidad gucci la
firma italiana ha sido noticia
recientemente por un acto de ocurrencia
creativa
este desfile lo abrieron modelos con
camisas de fuerza versión alta costura
en una protesta no planeada una de las
maniquís levantó así las manos ante los
fotógrafos y en ella se había escrito la
salud mental no es moda
desde la marca argumentaron que se
habían inspirado en las teorías de
fútbol sobre la humanidad y los
uniformes que bloquean y restringen
entonces la moda superficial iza o
reivindica
por suerte hoy contamos con la inclusión
está el vitíligo de winnie harlow pero
las editoriales y pasarelas se han
abierto a las cicatrices al enanismo al
síndrome de dawn
y aunque no lo mostrado podría recordar
la influencia de la anorexia en los 90
se adoraban sus efectos porque las
prendas caen mejor en cuerpos huesudos
como una percha
con estos ejemplos quiero mostraros que
lo que es bonito en un espacio y tiempo
determinado puede no serlo en otro que
la moda no es sólo un reflejo de lo
bello y atemporal puede ser una voz
consciente que somos vulnerables y
perecederos y en la paradoja de nuestra
fascinación por lo enfermo recibe un
indudable poder de atracción como los
amores contrariados sí señor todos en
algún momento vamos a estar enfermos es
un pasaporte de la vida por lo que a ver
si me explico el camuflaje estético es
una herramienta de supervivencia ante
aquello que tememos y a lo que nos
inscribimos como grupo
por eso os invito a que dejemos de
rechazar la moda como algo banal y
escuchemos su discurso antropológico su
capacidad para hablar de tus ansiedades
de tu existencia y de todo aquello que
te da miedo
[Aplausos]
[Música]